[Musique]
comment les demandeurs d'asile sont ils
répartis au sein de l'union européenne
début 2018 le président de la ligue
belge des droits de l'homme alexis de
soif déclaré que la belgique pouvait
décider de ne plus suivre le règlement
de dublin selon ce règlement c'est le
premier pays de l'union européenne dans
lequel le réfugié pose un pied qui est
en charge de sa demande d'asile
ce n'est qu'une faculté on pourrait
s'engager la belgique en disant nous
appliquons plus le règlement de dublin
cette question tous les états membres
peuvent se la poser peut-on décider de
ne plus respecter le règlement de dublin
le principe de base c'est celui du
premier pays membre dans lequel le
réfugié a été inscrit comme demandeur
d'asile
si un syrien entre en europe via
l'italie et vient faire une demande
d'asile en belgique
celle ci devra le renvoyer vers l'italie
qui devra elle prendre en charge la
procédure d'asile
résultat des pays comme la grèce ou
l'italie finissent par crouler sous les
procédures d'asile
la commission européenne a bien présenté
une réforme du système de dublin afin de
mieux répartir les migrants entre les
états membres
mais cette réforme n'a pas encore été
approuvé par le conseil européen
la règle du premier pays d'entrée doit
donc être toujours appliqué sauf dans
certains cas si l'état membre en
question présente de mauvaises
conditions d'accueil
c'est le cas de la grèce si le réfugié
un membre de sa famille proche dans un
autre état membre
il existe aussi deux exceptions qui
permette d'office de contourner le
règlement de dublin pour des raisons
humanitaires
si le réfugié es malade par exemple ou
pour des raisons de souveraineté un état
membre peut décider de prendre en charge
une demande d'asile
mais il s'agit bien là d'exception qui
ne peuvent pas remplacer la règle
générale du premier pays accueillant si
la belgique et d'autres états membres
décident de ne plus suivre le règlement
de dublin
ce serait donc contraire au droit
européen ce que dit alexis ii
et donc contestable
[Musique]